being behind on your bills can be a very
scary place starting baby step one is a
great goal but if you're behind right
now you need to get current on your
bills don't even worry about your
beginner emergency fund of $1,000 pay
your bills first you need to take care
of what we call the four walls these are
basic things we all need food shelter
and utilities transportation and
clothing so what do you do first
eat buy food for your family that's the
very first thing you do the next thing
you do is keep the lights and water on
after paying utilities take care of
shelter that means pay the rent or
mortgage then you move on to
transportation and once you know you can
get where you need to go with gas in the
tank then you can take care of your
basic clothing needs don't go all out on
brand name fashion just buy what you
need
here's a tip don't get behind on your
home and be current on your MasterCard
and your student loan if you're going to
be behind on something choose to hold
off on things that don't matter as much
they're called unsecured creditors
creditors that don't have any security
they don't have a lien on anything
they're not going to take away basic
necessities of your life if you have a
place to live it's warm and the lights
are on your stomach is full and you have
clothing to wear and a way to get to
work you live to fight another day the
four walls are in place and War II
starts to slip away when your lights are
about to be cut off but you've paid your
MasterCard bill that's when life starts
spinning out of control you won't win in
that situation put the four walls of
your home up first then work your way
through the other stuff it's all about
priorities